The GCF is 9 x squared y squared. Let's see why. This would be the prime
factorization for 45 x squared y cubed. And this would be the prime
factorization for 36 x to the fourth y squared z. I'm going to regroup my
numbers together so that we have the 2's together and the 3's together. I want
to find the lowest power of each factor that appears in both terms. We know that
3 appears in both terms, and in fact a power of 3 squared appears in both terms.
So that's going to start the product of my greatest common factor. This number
has a 5, however this number does not, so I can't list 5 as part of my greatest
common factor. However X is a factor that appears in both terms and we have a
power of X squared that is common between them. So we can list X squared in the
product of our GCF. And finally, they both share the lowest power of y squared,
so we can include that in our GCF as well. The greatest common factor is the
product of all of these factors together. So we have 9 times x squared times y
squared.